il est 4h du matin à Paris 6h à Moscou
quand Vladimir Poutine prend la parole
pour déclarer la guerre
j'ai pris la décision d'une opération
militaire spéciale
le but est la protection des personnes
qui pendant 8 ans ont subi les abus et
le génocide du régime de kiaf
des accusations infondées de génocide
que Vladimir Poutine utilise pour
justifier son invasion il accuse
l'Ukraine de s'en être pris au pro russe
des territoires séparatistes il annonce
qu'il visera l'armée ukrainienne
[Musique]
pour se faire nous viserons la
démilitarisation et la dénazification de
l'Ukraine alors que les chats russes
entrent en Ukraine Vladimir Poutine
prétend ce matin ne pas vouloir occuper
le pays en même temps nous n'avons pas
l'intention d'occuper l'Ukraine nous
n'avons pas l'intention d'imposer quoi
que ce soit à qui que ce soit mais le
ton martial est sans ambiguïté et enfin
de discours le président russe menace
tous ceux qui souhaiteraient s'opposer à
ces manœuvres
essaierai de nous arrêter et de créer
davantage de menaces pour notre pays
pour notre peuple
je devrais savoir que la réponse de la
Russie sera immédiate et entraînera des
conséquences telles que vous n'en avez
jamais affronté dans votre histoire
pour certains experts il y aurait dans
ces mots une référence à peine voilée à
l'arme nucléaire